I now like to consider a very unusual
problem and we saw a demo of this
suppose you have a yo-yo and the yo-yo
has inner radius B and an outer radius R
and the yo-yo is rolling without
slipping along the ground and what we
have here is we're pulling the yo-yo
with a string that's wrapped around the
spool and I want to find F max such that
it rolls without slipping if I don't
pull it hard enough the wheel will roll
without slipping and if I pull it harder
then this F max the wheel will start to
slip so now let's analyze this problem
and let's use our dynamics approach
let's choose an I hat J hat k hat as
before we'll define an angle theta and
now we'll apply both Newton's second law
for linear motion and our torque about
the center of mass now we have to
consider our forces so I'm going to put
the forces on this diagram we have the
normal force from the ground pointing up
we have the gravitational force pointing
down and remember it's rolling without
slipping so the wheel is the contact
point is instantaneously at rest but
because the center of mass of the wheel
is accelerating once again in order to
keep a equal to our alpha then we need
some type of torque that will produce a
nonzero alpha and that's going to come
from a non zero static friction so once
again we have a case unlike a wheel
which is just rolling along a horizontal
plane because we're pulling this yo-yo
string the static friction is not zero
static friction depends on everything
else that's happening in the system and
now we can apply Newton's second law F
equals MA and so in our x-direction we
have F minus F equals MA
and if we look at the torque about the
center of mass is ICM alpha then this is
our X equation now here the both the
pulling force and the static friction
both exert torques about the center of
mass the static friction will exert a
torque in the direction K hat and the
pulling force will exert a torque in the
minus K hat direction
so our torques the normal force does not
produce any torque about the center of
mass nor does gravity so what we have is
FS times the radius of the wheel that is
the torque due to static friction minus
B times the pulling force F and that's
equal to IC m alpha so we have our two
dynamic equations and again that's
recopy our rolling without slipping
condition now expressed in terms of
acceleration so now what I'd like to do
is solve for this force F and the way
I'll do it is I'll write down from this
condition alpha in terms of a over R and
from this equation I have that so alpha
is a over R and from the top equation I
have that a is f minus F static over M R
times R so I can replace the alpha in
this equation and I get FS R minus bf is
ICM F minus FS over M R and now I just
need to collect terms
I'll bring the static friction turn to
this side and my F term to that side and
so I get FS times R and when I bring the
static friction term over to that other
side I get I see M over m R let's just
check dimensions
I see M is M R squared so this terms
have the dimensions of length
looks like I'm okay and now I bring the
F to the other side and I get F times B
plus I see M over m R I can now solve
for F and I get F static R plus I cm and
over R it's a complicated answer divided
by B plus I see M divided by M R now if
I want to ask the question what is the
maximum force I can pull in which it
just slips what's physically happening
is the harder I pull the bigger the
static friction is I pull harder static
friction gets bigger I pull harder
static friction gets bigger but static
friction can only have a maximum value
that hasn't changed the maximum value of
static friction is the coefficient of
static friction times a normal force
which in this case is just normal
balancing gravity mg so this is the
maximum value that static friction can
have and so now I get F max you know
this is again a little complicated you s
mg times R plus I see M divided by M R
divided by B plus I see M divided by M R
and that is the maximum force that I can
pull this yo-yo with that it still rolls
without slipping